[Music]
good morning John is Tuesday September
11th that date sure is never gonna sound
the same again you can tell by my
sun-dappled face that I'm doing this
video late in the afternoon it's been a
busy day
I've had a lot of stuff to do I still
have more stuff to do one of those
things I have to do is a search for a
very important thing and I'm going to
bring you on that search with me this is
actually the scarier part of my basement
there's two parts part where I'll spend
almost all of my time which is right
there you see me there every day there's
this scary bug which is light bulbs that
I almost run into all the time
but the reason why I'm taking you down
here is in this hole here there is
something important in this little hole
and that important thing hopefully we
will all get to see soon hopefully I'm
not positive I know sometimes it's not
here sometimes it is it's a bit of a
mystery honestly
the important thing is much better
because in spiders is it over here
no it's not over here but up here no no
lots of scary things but not what I'm
looking for
I sit in here oh yeah there it is
I told you it was very important what
are you doing in the floor kitty I'm
going to give you this wants to be away
from us and when she wants that she
comes into the scary hole down here and
gets in the floor which is the ceiling
of the basement yeah some people have
indoor cats
some people have outdoor cats we have an
in-floor cat and all that build-up was
just for that last joke holy Lord check
this out somebody made a brotherhood 2.0
recycling bin on the top it says
Brotherhood 2.0 and on the sides it has
a note about Eko geeking on the other
side it has a note about John's books
and on the front of that's the world
suck index Brotherhood 2.0 helping to
recycle and making garbage men extremely
confused I also wanted to share with you
a story that I got from the person who
sent me those pictures he was really hot
that day and being a nerdfighter she
doesn't have very much experience with
sunlight she got painted on her arms and
face by her
friends uh joke Tok fun fun time paint
paint paint and then she got a sunburn
except on the places that were painted
and so now she's red and white polka
dotted nerdfighter
hey I enjoyed getting those pictures in
that story thank you Mary
recycling nerdfighters who nerdy anyway
today is September 11th and it sure
hasn't stopped affecting the world I
remember when I was really little adults
would always talk about where they were
when John F Kennedy was assassinated and
obviously that day for us was the
morning of September 11th 2001 I was
asleep in my dorm room and my roommate
woke me up and I thought that he meant
like a Cessna crashed into the World
Trade Center and yeah I remember not
believing it for a really long time I'm
just going to ask you John where were
you cuz I don't think I know that and
everybody else too
where were you guys anyway
I'll see you tomorrow